hey y'all nico tortorella here star of
the new walking dead world beyond
i am here with buzzfeed today to read
some of your
thirsty tweets
i had a dream i was in a serious
relationship with nico tortorella
imagine my disappointment when i woke up
this morning
dreams are the best right we can like
live out our full
fantasies i have a lot of dreams nico
tortorella's smile is so beautiful
i'm dead dead and gone turned into a
zombie
r-i-p i'm coming for you that's not in
i was just continuing watching make it
or break it
nico tortorella i want to make emo
babies with you
heart y'all throw back make it or break
it
ugh razor razor sharp i missed that show
that was the beginning
of it all let's make some emo babies i
feel like all babies
are emo babies right every time i see
nico tortorella on tv i consider selling
my soul
to marry them you don't have to sell
your soul
to marry anyone hold on to that you're
gonna need it for the marriage part
trust me i'm married you need some soul
nico tortorella is my sexual
orientation honestly same like
i agree this is my sexual orientation
this is my gender identity
it's complicated and nuanced but like is
in everybody's
nobody not a single soul no living
organism
me nico tortorella and i are actually
together they just
don't know that skull face i know it now
let's uh like maybe go on a date first
see if we vibe
like can we go from there i may be
married but i'm still available
got a nice little arrangement over here
excuse me
as i like all of nico tortorella's hairy
chest and beard instagrams
that may take a minute um so you are
excused for the day
free that hair no matter who you are or
where you lie
on the gender spectrum we all have it
but only some of us are supposed to
shave it y'all let that hair free
honestly it's so much harder oh man
younger tv is so good mates i'm
definitely oh this isn't an
english accent oh man yoga tv is so good
mates i'm definitely not just watching
it for nico tortorella's abs
you know abs are not it they're not all
of
it takes a lot of [ __ ] work to get
some abs
and it's like is it really ever worth it
i don't know
love your body no matter what it looks
like i would love to be in the middle of
a razor
diamond sandwich make it or break it
yeah y'all these make it or break it
throwbacks i am here
for this a razor damon sandwich that
sounds delicious
actually i'm here for that footlong oh i
want niko's order
nico's orderellas i can't even say my
own name
i want nico tortorella's arms to squash
me like a walnut
i'm here for it come here come here
i actually can't watch nico tortorella
without getting
wet i'm wet right now google
disclosure how to get niko tortorella to
sit on my face
it's not that difficult i'm like kind of
a demisexual like
i need some emotional attachment before
i just go sit on someone's face but like
i'm very emotional you know like it's
not that difficult for me to get
emotionally
attached are you are you emotionally
attached right now i'm emotionally
attached
i love you next i would pay niko
tortorella money to
literally spit on me y'all i feel like
this was written
before the new world you know the
pandemic the revolution
the election we're not spitting anymore
uh sorry for being crude
but nico tortorella can murder my
vagina i hear you i guess i just never
really
understood this this saying like murder
my vagina
was amanda bynes the one that really
brought this this phrase to
the zeitgeist like i don't want to
murder your vagina like can't we just
like
hang out a little bit me and your vagina
can like hold hands
you know i don't want to murder it
that's too much for me i feel pressured
i don't work well under pressure nico
tortorella more like [ __ ] me
that no no no see that's that's good the
timing you can't write this
i guess you can because someone did nico
tortorella
can punch me in the face spit in my
mouth
fist me and all that any time any day i
feel like i have to take some of these
jewels off for this
this could hurt ah i'm ready again with
the spitting nico
tortorella my [ __ ] is
red d like i feel like that wet ass
buzzy
like it's a real thing i'm ready i
genuinely want nico tortorella to
curb stomp my hole y'all
google that or don't whatever you're
into curb stop my whole see what you
come up with
let me know find me on instagram send me
that dm of what you find out curb stop
my whole
i love you you nasty ass [ __ ]
[Music]
you